hi guess what my tripod is today take a
guess
not my best look oh my worst look
today's tripod is brought to you by a
paper towel roll and there's a tripod
sitting legit right next to it
well today it's got a crane because I
had so much stuff to do but not a lot of
time to do it I gotta take Maddy to the
beds I'm pretty much one of those
obsessive dog moms who it's like it any
sign of anything out of the ordinary I'm
like we're packing up we're going to the
vet so at the vet Maddy was all clear
he's healthy he's perfect he is my
beautiful baby
I wouldn't met Jenna at the mall had to
shop and do a few free Indy 500 things
I'm looking for Jenna she's she's here
oh yeah I've definitely screw it up I'm
all the way back down here now I'm going
to Indianapolis tonight
that just came down it was like here
anyone like that it was like this and
now it's like this
we share and now here I am in the
kitchen talking to you guys but I should
be finishing packing is also my
wonderful manager Leila's birthday today
so before we hop on an extremely late
flight we're gonna go celebrate a
birthday so let's go celebrate Leila and
then hop on a flight
yeah it's dark and it's dark for an
appropriate reason because it's living
21 p.m. and we're heading to the airport
just left dinner with Leila and man I'm
tired we have too many cupcakes too much
birthday here we go 9:22 p.m. what times
I know they will be good we got us a
free market 939 holy crap we bought in
ten minutes
look at this front facing camera it
looks like I got hit by
after the Indy 500 all right guys we
made it and good thing nobody needs CPR
there's like 6:00 a.m.
it's barely out of service one bag get
out I need to go to bed immediately
I've been sleeping this entire day
trying to readjust my sleeping schedule
we are off to the burger bash with Steak
and Shake so this is the camera that
we're gonna be vlogging with this is the
8 dean the camera that we're going to be
taking photos with it's elder sm3 cuz
they'll look better I'm learning and
then for time lapses I've got a GoPro
somewhere and of course the iPhone for
pictures are you ready for this actually
really nice I didn't think it would fit
me but it fit me very nicely well that's
our Sunday finest for race day with them
I just changed my clothes in the car
because that's how we do it
Oh always a struggle
you guys we are here at the burger bash
did you write in that in the in the
parade last year with with Graham last
year was so fun it was my first time
really getting into the whole IndyCar
scene and I got to ride in the car with
grim ray Hall in the parade
and now here I am back again with Steak
N Shake and it's been so much fun
Justine does a video blog when we call
it that yeah you got that all right we
just did our fun interview on the stage
we didn't get any like burger yet well
guess what they're still there let's get
a burger and a milkshake
don't change
let's go party
so sad it's hard the last thing I want
to do right now is leave - yes - oh we
have to get up early so good dude she is
so Gauri well I guess we should go to
bed now good night guys
see you at the Indy 500